Yes, I'm actually a modern
[ __ ], so if you
lock me up in the city for more than two weeks then
I'll be a rocker on the outside
but on the inside I know what I'm
doing, I think if you're with
my great colleague  I'm talking to people I have
a lot of respect for, if they brought 15%
home, they would no
longer have a job, they would have a big problem.
Welcome to the OMR podcast.
I've had a lot of stars in the last few years,
you can say from music, from art, but
also from entrepreneurship  Today
I have someone who you would think was
actually a great musician maybe
or a painter in reality he has a
media agency so please be sure to
check YouTube or Instagram if it is
a visual highlight here as a guest is Frank
Lankers founder of mediapan  hi Frank hi
Philip I'm really happy,
thank you so where do we start? So
today you run a very well-running
media agency in
Badenbaden that you own 100% and it's called Mediaplan. I
think it makes around 140 in sales if people
see you at the airport or the train station
or something like that  then you wouldn't
assume that, you agree with me or I agree with
you 100%, I'm
proud of it too, I would think you're an
artist in some
form or something else, yes I'm
constantly asked whether I'm a painter
or a DJ and I feel  I always feel like
a rock star that's why I think your
trade fair is so cool but no, much, much cooler
Media but tell me a little bit about
how it came about for you so your your your
entrepreneurial life is
already very impressive the company how
did it start so itself
a story that my father doesn't
like to hear son of was the worst thing
I could experience my father built a really
great marketing service company
weter marketing and everything is
clear Frank you are going in that direction you
rock it and had long hair I
prefer long as a tennis coach  set off
but quickly realized I was the
worst son of and then
went to London, worked for an agency for
the music industry and
realized wow, there's something like that called
response, it's something really cool and I ended up bringing
it with me from the USA and
came back  I got to know the metro group
and they said Frank,
open two agencies, open a
media agency where you will carry out the
digitalization of the
metrooguppe's media and a
production house and at that time I had two weeks,
boring name mediapan,
nothing else occurred to me during this
time, okay and from that  A
company developed that
was initially limited to Metro and was no
longer a son of but I wanted to
rock the world and was cut short
and how come someone now
say that you now work in the London
music industry, I can
imagine that  Do you also know
roughly how to apply
and then fight on like that, but
how did you respond to the topic? So
you mean response marketing, respon
marketing, so back then it was like that, I
walked through London through the streets
I always walked  Propagandists were
too enthusiastic who simply managed
to sell all kinds of kitchen appliances
and then
I started thinking about it, man, you have to be
able to transport it electronically somehow at
that time and I flew to the USA
and then saw the first
attempts at teleshopping and it caught
my fancy  so fascinated because I said
WoW and immediately came back and
thought so we can jump into his
money storage, I want to
build an address storage and it was 94 so I
gave the Metro the chance
and said that the
first projects Bosch roventa would be digitized  in the
metro how do we get it digitized
and we made the first TV Schust
and that's how teleshopping and TV
came into being in Germany so we have
full pioneering spirit, full of courage, the
broadcasters threw their hands up over their heads back then
and we said
that's what we believe  It's our turn that
Heß your specialization was drtv, which
means direct response TV advertising
on television and immediately after
the flight you measure what's happening on the
website, for example, exactly right, which is
why for me at the time the
most fascinating thing was to sit in call centers
and see what you have  a
tv sport what's happening the lines have
partially broken down you
rocked and if you look today that
's data so we've always
worked with numbers we've always
said marketing with numbers that's our
DNA and I loved that so much I
think it's great if you  are measurable if
you become transparent if you
can build something like that can build companies
that means even though people would now
perceive you as an artist, you are
also a very toothy person I have
a DNA and I'm lucky that
life has given me a great mindset  what
is a lot of creativity and
creativity doesn't stand in the way of numbers
but I always associate creativity and
entrepreneurship with numbers and
everyone in our team does too and that
always fascinated me and how
did you get to
know the metro as a young entrepreneur
a contact with my father because
Mr. Conradi himself
said at some point Junior came there precisely because
he was involved in his parents'
company, thought it was quite good,
felt good energy, smart guy,
we can do something with that and thank you for
believing me and  connected with
my father then and that's in the last
20 30 years but you've
found numerous other customers always with the
pitch so to speak direct response yes in the
beginning it was very strong
trading companies publishers who simply
said how can we grow how do
we learn our  Knowing customers and
we simply built up this whole structure
in Europe and
then it grew into more and more. People
suddenly thought of the TV. The TV
developed at some point. At
some point, the connotation of DRTV was completely negative,
but everyone tried it.
Then it went on  In the end, the digital industry
emerged as nothing other
than working with numbers in other
electronic ways and Mediaplan has
always had the DNA and we have the
topic that we still do today with 15 30
minutes according to the American Veld,
but in this way we simply give companies
the opportunity to provide services
To present products and company philosophies in a completely different way, you have to say that
the market is dominated by
various large agencies. What you
do there is, in the end, response is
a specialty, but in the end it's
about media planning, so you are an
agency that ultimately helps companies with that
your media budget, your marketing budget
to be spent sensibly in the sense of where do
you spend it so that the most comes from it so
now somehow
buy TV advertising, buy Google advertising,
buy magazine ads
and and and and that's
essentially what big
agencies or big agency networks do in Germany
So international players, you're
absolutely right, so we have a lot of
respect from the others, but we're
different, we don't say we
're an agency anymore, we're grow partners, why
because we don't wait, send us a
briefing, we do something about it,
we do entrepreneurship  We'll
go in with you and let's say in 3
years we need 100,000 new customers
and need brand awareness plus so
and so much percent and are already
integrated into the strategy process. That's
the big big difference, that's why we do
n't say we're an agency
for something really bad  It
simply doesn't do justice to the agency, it
would be too small, but we manage
to support companies and
we have supported so many exciting projects in
the last few years, so you
can start with Asam Kos, for example from
day one, transforming the
teleshopping company  today to one of
the top cosmetic brands in Germany
360° campaigns transformed from an
electronic company today to
a large digital branding
marketpler super great Emmer mattresses
one of the success stories we
have we do Emmer are very
happy great partner from the first day
Dennis was already
schmol  People, I know where we
were at Emma's for the first time,
I think there were ten more people in a small office
and got us and said what can
we do, what
exactly did you do there?  The
first ones said let's
try TV oh that doesn't work, we are a
digital product and we have
simply managed to bring together
different types of media again and again
because we
have the data, we have models and
models with us like today from over
1000 campaigns in the last few years  In the
next 30 years,
we can simply connect them and make
predictions. Let's meet the target group
where they are. We don't
just rely on the classic tools, we have
developed our own tools that
help us companies today to use the one € in a
completely different and precise way  and
thus to create growth, that means we are
clearly building branding for
small branded goods companies in many
digital companies and it is going
excellently and so we have who
knows what, Mirko with Mr spacks, one of
our big projects but also new
great companies like waterdrop where Martin
So W was completely 40 industry where we
always don't know exactly where we can
shoot how do we put together 360° campaigns
correctly with our data know-how
you don't do the creation s you
really only do the purchasing of the media i.e.
the distribution so to speak it doesn't matter
the internal we have
creation partners we are also
very much involved in this that is very important
the process but we separated ourselves from it
we had our own
production team we
left it to the great
experts but we are really creative
and strategic so that means
most of them  Agencies are involved in
campaigning and we are very much the
creative partner at the forefront of the strategy
because we can tell at the front if
you are creative in the strategy and
have the courage to do it. At the end of the
campaigning you will come out and that
sets us apart dramatically  Other
agencies recently I was
at Kates and they told me
they don't do TV advertising anymore, for example. No, it does
n't surprise you at all because I actually think it's
brave. I think it's great. I
might do it differently, but they have
a reason for it and we do  See,
we have campaigns and
TV advertising isn't important either,
that's why it's very clear and that's
the nice thing right now, especially in our
market, we have completely different technical
requirements and it's developing
which platform gives you the most money
right now, so when you say about  all
customers, where does the most money flow
in? So it's clear that the combination
of linear TV and digital measures
out of home is totally
up-and-coming, of course radio is totally
up-and-coming but the combination is what makes
radio is really up-and-coming, yes for us
it's crazy  Exciting, we
have just launched some really great campaigns
Mara, super successful
campaigns where we suddenly actively shape target groups in a
different way than a defensive medium
and we
succeeded brilliantly, but it's always the mix that counts and
we just go in very, very deeply, we
roll up our arms and  go very
deep into the lowest cellars of the
results and the numbers and then
you can and do also make
media genres measurable where everyone says
how do we get into the measurable and
we get it done and tell me what about
all the new modern things
tiktok Netflix and something like that are full of course
full and streaming TV
is of course becoming more and more important it's
really fun we sat
together with Netflix again last week and for us
it's about shopping not
making placement yes both both for us it's
always important to be a pioneer what  can
we do what is not basic and we
want to leave the basic and we know
very well we will g with our
partners we don't say customers we
say partner is our culture we
want to go there with our partners that's
why L there that and that designing and
especially Netflix  There is incredible data,
data and data matching, how can we
build completely new paths together? Tell me
now, because data is a bit
organic, but what
exactly are you looking at now? You now want to take
Emma mattresses or take them from me
if you  Do you also advertise for
Netflix so that Netflix gets new customers
or
just because that's a customer of yours
when you start now, what are you looking at?
So mattress buyers can
be anyone and what do you tend to do?
So we're clearly looking again and
again  match the target group
match how does the target group match in
media behavior but we then
clearly match with the results every day what do
we experience what do we learn every day
and it's an insane amount of work you
have to have the people who
really want to do it and who have the DNA  You
also have to read the numbers and that's
very, very important these days. You
can have crazy data as an agency
if you can't read it
if you can't handle it. At
Emmer, we take a
very close look at the reporting match every day
and optimize it  Then
campaigns change media mixes and that
always brings success, these incredible
successes, these large networks,
i.e. we're talking about
Omnicom WPP and large, listed
billion-dollar corporations that
certainly have a lot more data because
they have even more
customers. How do you differentiate yourself?  in
this this game I don't know how
much data they have I know how much
data we have and how much fun we
have with the data and that's maybe
exactly the difference we love the
data so we love our numbers and
of course we can you
imagine 30 years and there is
n't that much that has been around for 30 years,
we've experienced a lot, but
we also fall back on it and we
deal with this data and you have to
want it, you have to invest a lot of time
and you just have to  say
this is not a customer but is a
project that I love that I would like to
support for several years. You are also
involved, so to speak, so you are
involved in the success or does it just work that
way? You get a budget that you have to spend and then you get a commission on it, um both
We like to let ourselves be evaluated by the
company's success, campaign success,
and go along with it. We
are incredibly flexible. For us, that's the
most important thing. That's what sets us apart
quite dramatically. We don't want a one-
step business. We don't want a
short-term business. We've been working with
you for years and there  We are
incredibly grateful because all of our
partners have benefited us for a long time, why
because we
build up entrepreneurship together so well, we are
like our own marketing department and
we match each other, that's how we see each other and that's
how we are used as
much as we have to  You can still plan for it if
you say okay, I'm going to spend
100 million a year
on you, how much is
left because you have a
bit of a stake in it, so we're talking about 3, 4% or
20% or something like that, that would be nice, that's how it is in
Dubai  Markets, that's how the other
markets are and of course it's the
same with our big competitors. The plan is
a little different, so we're
happy with less but in the long term and then you can also
say okay because everyone sells  Mattress
somehow gets 1 euro or
something like that, we get a mattress then
sent to you, but there are also those available, there
are also okay, so
in this case not and of course
that can only ever be a small part
because we have a basis for them  We have to
work but we are sometimes
still brave and say we have a
certain basis, let's
develop something beyond that together and we have
already had companies involved that have
said we can't afford media in that
sense and but we believe
in you  and we also believe in them, but
the 140 million that you
make in sales is, so to speak,
including what you
pass on directly to the respective
television stations or or platform or
is that what your
prion revenue is, so to speak,
that is, budgets and
Of course, these are not the ones who pay, these are
the numbers that you see somewhere, that are
floating around somewhere and we are
grateful for them too, but there are different
ways. Mediaplan consists of
different companies and we
invest ourselves, but we do
other things, we are active abroad
and yes, that means it's okay, I
notice that
it's not that easy to understand, but
still, so I'll try to
understand you never sold the company
in the last few years,
all of the agencies were also
sold to the independent agencies  large
networks partly in private equity
why not you have had offers so
luckily I have had offers but
luckily I always stay
true to myself with us it is incredibly important
I have an incredibly high level of responsibility
towards the Irish team when you look we
are around  The 100 people with us and the
majority of the people remain loyal to us, they
are incredibly loyal and I just feel like
jumping out of bed every morning and I feel like joining
this team, I have some breathing room because
I see the world turning more and more
In our brandformance ways in which
we are there is now
maybe 10 20% of the potential and
we are moving forward and that's why
we say no, we are different, we are
valuable, you can't pay for that with money
until now and we  walking
this path together up to now means
maybe one day when I'm
100 years old, but then I
still have 45 years, okay, that means
sales aren't an issue for now, but there were offers, so what's that, so
maybe it's
a number where you would become weak
So there's an idea of ​​what
an agency like this is worth in the end, so
of course somehow Z times or 15 times or
20 times your result depending on the
growth, so I'll put it or h
completely right, so that's the
standard way but with us that's also the case
again, it's very difficult for you to measure our value
because the team is so valuable
because it's different, but the
team is also, so to speak, as we
often know from creative agencies, also
involved with you through a partner model, so to speak, or is your
company, there are models with us  Where
people are involved, they know that
too and everyone knows me as a
generous person. Nobody falls
behind here. We try to
be incredibly fair and my word knows why
they
are there
That's not the classic
kind of part. We're really different
from everyone else. There's no
standard. We give ourselves incredible
freedom and every opinion counts and we
always find ways that
aren't standardized. That's why
everyone with us will first
think about it  and
we've already thought about it, of course, and we
know we appreciate our
colleagues from the big agencies.
I don't think we're a small player either. We
're self-confident, but we're calm,
although if I
say now, what I could see
is 140 million  Of course, a lot of money
at the same time if it's the
budget turnover or the media turnover
passes through the i, so to speak, then it's
not that much because
of course some companies spend
203 million a year alone
on marketing and and and the
communication then needs  you only have 4 f
customers of this type and then you're there.
So that's it. I'll just imagine that
one Emma alone will probably
spend 40 million at the level of 30. Very
nice, we're not quite there yet, but
we want to get there  okay okay, so that
means but there aren't that
many customers that you have, so we have around
40 customers, just around 40
campaigns and customers are well distributed
for us, which is also very important and I attach great
importance to it and the team puts a lot of emphasis on it  It's
more important that we have a good
base of many interesting companies and
companies
that are still small at the beginning often come to us. We
often provide fresh money. That's what sets
us apart dramatically. We don't go into
the pitch where models
and conditions change  Make an inquiry, we
're really up for it when
companies come to us, say we're
just starting up and look, we have a
budget of 100,000 and in zi years we'll be
at 3 million, which means that if
you think about it, you have 40 customers, 100 people,
then one person can  can do about
half three customers yes yes and
you can do that with us you can also come to us
sometimes people from other
agencies say which customer should
I work on and we
then say 1 2 3 4 5 what I can't do but
you can and  That's the learning
with us, everyone develops differently, you
can see that, we're not an agency, you're noticing a certain recession at the moment, you
hear a lot
about consumer restraint in Germany, perhaps
also about reduced
marketing budgets. That also applies to you, of
course, but to us  That
also challenges us in a good way, that we
simply say now is the time when you
reposition yourself, where you
remain a troll, otherwise your
partners, your customers will help you, now it's time to
stick together and move forward and we
are convinced that everything
will get better again  because we also see that in
our area, of course, the consumer has
the consumer data to work with,
so you have the freedom
to spend other budgets where
many people still have difficulty in branding, from the
luxury segment, but we provide
incredible support, we stick together with all
our partners and so on  Schönberg will be back
next year W a good
year okay so that's more like hope
or no no that's already
deposited so we can see that although
consumer behavior will remain difficult but
we have identified ways and
defined ways where you
can afford marketing again  to spend because it's
simply more controlled and
predictable platform-related
or or no that's the really important thing
not platform-related but
target group-related so we know
exactly the target group you want to
grow you want success let's get it in
the way let's work on it  Turn the wheel
and that's what makes us special, but
now we say that the fastest
growing platform in your entire
portfolio is probably already
tiktok, namely where the most
money is spent, a lot is
spent on YouTube, tiktok but also
linear TV. I'm a huge fan  Of that,
you
still get values ​​that are still
fascinating, so to the branding
structure to the very clear rear trans
yes even there, so it's clear the mix
makes it if you were to only switch on linear TV now
it won't work
But in the mix it's still a driver
and a really cool engine and what does
radio advertising do? You just mentioned
what does what does regionality, it's
great if you do TV linear, for example,
combine it with radio
regionality
and we have excellent
results  Now achieved at smara where
you already thought, wow, it's going to be damn
hard and we've proven that you
can get it done through hard optimization and
really through testing and building,
okay, there
's a competitor, I'm
always in danger of confusing it
I think the largest
independent German media agency group
is servicepl ne, funnily enough,
their name is mediapan, they are called
serviceepan,
they are again a factor of 10, I don't know,
bigger, probably, yes, there are
many more independent players, yes, there
are two three g agencies in Hamburg
exactly exactly I would
say those are the ones so we do
n't look at any I ca
n't even tell you because we live in
our own cosmos there are many
good many many good but we
also talk to many so they are of use to us
and and  and you also go into the pitches a lot yourself,
so you're the one who, so to
speak, convinces the customer
that they're working with you,
so first of all, the whole team is
much better than me in detail, but of
course you still have a
different experience in 30 years and  I just
enjoy it 90% of our aququise comes from
recommendations and we are very proud
and very grateful and I can
sometimes join in, but I mean you are
aware that you as a person
seem completely different now when you
see yourself like that than you do now  So to speak, the normal
person that I now imagine
walking into a pitch from the media agency
is aware of it, is it also a
bit of marketing or is it just
like that, that's how
I am actually and then
I was in Paris many
years ago  in the takeover interview and they
said to me, okay Frank, you're now joining the
network and that will be your position
on board with us and I
looked at the people, I looked at myself,
I don't judge anyone, I don't judge
anyone and it's not based on external appearances.
I've always been like that  different but I
just thought okay if you think I
fit in and then you have to
laugh yourself. So I'm incredibly
adaptable but I also give everyone
the space to be exactly as they are and
that's the only wish I have in life
because of that  I'm like that, but do
you have the feeling that it helps to
stand out a little bit in business terms or is it
perhaps even a shame that people say
I'm a little worried that the
maybe a little bit
of a question never even
thought that far, maybe I'm like that, I'm
not like that  Well, I'm a person who
gives everything to everyone and that's why I never have
negative thoughts, I'm always positive
and I'm the way I am, maybe
it doesn't come across to some people, I do
n't experience it often, so most of them are actually the ones who
say okay, you  You're exactly the way
you are, please stay that way, but I'm
not basing it on any calculation or
anything. I can't believe that's
my heart, my soul, but it's
hard to imagine that someone like you
now experiences the way I do every day for
decades  in Baden Baden you're
just sitting there walking into the office and I mean
you already live in a global
lifestyle I know somehow from time to time in
the south of France you're friends with Robert Geist you guys
so that's
a bit of a part of life go to it yes
I'm on  I'm a od a gipsi
so if you
lock me up in the city for more than two weeks then I'll go
in. That's why a lot of people ask me Frank where do
you actually live and in the suitcase and
that's a huge compliment so I
get my creativity
my energy when traveling somewhere I'm
going last week we were in India
and it's also possible that I just
register in agencies and say
hey, how do you do that, I want to learn from you
and that's how Mediaplan grew up too,
we have an inquiry  had
15 years ago to India
daily newspapers in
India we didn't know that much about
India we rocked it and that's
exactly mediaapan that's team with us
there are no borders we are limitless
and everyone wants to make a difference and
I'm the same way  and that gives me
freedom and that's why I
still feel like it, even after 30 years. I
can't believe myself, you can see my
horror, but I feel like it every morning
and I'm the way I
am now every day, so I mean I'm
in now  I've heard a lot of stories here recently
and also a lot of
dazzling founders and then there was a
crypto boom, for example where a lot of people
who had a very relaxed
life, so to speak, suddenly
crypto was gone and then their lives were also
a bit gone, but you do the
math  Well, you, I've
looked at least once, you also make
several million results, at least what
you can see in the JR, we'll
make that clear otherwise it would be
bad, but of course I calculate,
I'm a very down-to-earth person,
I love living, but  For me,
material things aren't important at all,
but that means you're one of those
people with, say, many
millions in annual results who still
say, well, I don't like the money
that much after 100% thanks and that
's very important for me  I ca
n't tell you either, so my CFO
sometimes despairs with me because it doesn't matter
what the numbers are, it doesn't bother me that much,
but I'm worried that it will happen at some point, I mean
you too h yes responsibility for
all the employees D that
maybe that will happen somehow  There could be a year
where suddenly it's minus
or 5 6 7 million and suddenly
the firmer breaks away and then
you're standing there you don't have no, not at all
because medapan is so healthy and
even we could do 3 4 5  Years of
understanding but I know myself
Entrepreneurship means ups and downs
after 30 years you know that and I
experienced it myself in my parents' house
I have many friends we have a
large network but I know exactly what
we are doing you can meet me at 3 in the morning
I know exactly where we're shooting,
what we're doing and that's very solid, so
I'm a bit of a
rocker on the outside but on the inside
I know what I'm doing and I
also attach great importance to it  You
said it well. Responsibility is something
very important. What prompted me
to start internationalization now, so I've always done it, so to speak.
Germany, Austria,
Switzerland, I've noticed a little bit.
Now you're also doing Dubai,
why
Dubai  I
came to Dubai for the first time, I
hated it, I thought how could you
go to Dubai and I
was in Sri Lanka myself at the time, when a
bad attack suddenly
happened on Ayurveda, I was one of the last Germans to
get out and because I
protected the people  and said with
the energy I don't want to
go home, I'll stay there and then said
where can I go now, away from Sri
Lanka back to Germany, I want to
process it first and I landed in Dubai
and found a place there
and there  I
stayed for a long time and got to know the country's
people's traditions in a completely different way and got to
know the locals,
which simply gave me a new
horizon in life and I
also saw wow Dubai is a
marketplace of great people just
like Mediaplan so there must be  what
exehen there's a connection there's
a connection and I've been
dealing with it for a year and a half what does that
mean what does that mean for business
and of course many of our big partners
are already incredibly successful over there it's a
cash purchase for many groups
then I thought about where ours is  Niche
again I'm always looking for niches
and pioneers and I've noticed
in our area that there are a lot of
great digital companies over there,
7000 start-ups every year
from all over the world and you meet
fascinating people there South America
America Europe Africa from everywhere and
everyone  wants to make a difference and we believe
that many of these companies also
see Germany and above all Dach or Europe as a goal again and
we hold the flag high, we still believe
in our country and say
okay, we are here, we have the team
here and as soon as possible  you need the bridge to Europe
we are here mediaapan is here
and it's going great the hot EU
your approach is international companies from
the Arab world who come to Germany and
bring you an office
but you're not doing business now
that you're imitating German customers, so to speak
Dubai brings that that's still to come that's
still to come we are from government
protected is very very important over there
and that's also something nice if you
have the opportunity the government says
here I support you come over
then get involved with you and you
can also get government orders  assume
that now comes in the second step, we
always have to go a little slow so
that we don't overextend ourselves because
people are still
important to us, we can't just
hire 50 people who don't fit in with us,
that's not our culture,
do everything step by step  Step and get
out of your heart but of course also out of your
brain and that's what's happening right now because
you're a lot of the suburbs yourself
now I'm a lot of the suburbs myself and that's
incredibly fun for me because the
energy over there is that way of
getting together I'll help you come  over and
even if you are perhaps a competitor, you
are open, you say hey, it's cool
that you're here, come and you can ask
people who have lived a lot of life questions
about all sorts of topics, everyone will
help you, everyone will have time and time
is the most valuable thing we have
Life there is a certain kind of reluctance in
Germany, let's
say these clichés towards Dubai, it's
somehow influencers who
save taxes and you don't experience that
at all, so
I experience it here, which I also understand
and  Some friends say to me, we
can make you feel at home in Dubai, we can
do business there. I've
only had positive experiences so far. I find
it fascinating. I'm naturally
skeptical about some things,
but I've been able to learn a lot
from locals about how things really work
Clearly from Saudi Arabia and so on we
can't ignore it at some point it will
come and I love the world I would
like to have 50% of my team from India
from China everywhere we are working
on it too we have no limits
medapan is limitless but we
want to  best the best we want to
be a platform for good souls and the best nohaau and there Dubi is the
first way and that goes further that's
why our journey is far from
over but currently
most people are in badenbahen in Berlin
and badenbaden and  It's hard
for you or people to have offspring
at all, but we're
super happy, people
really enjoy coming to us because they just
know they're getting further, they're allowed to
move forward as a person and with us there's
no whole come to us and and you're
allowed  everything you're not in
some silo but rock with us
and develop with us and with us you can do it all the
same with us everyone can
become something, the whole topic of
AI now plays a big role for you
everyone is talking about it, it's also a
data topic in the  In a certain
form, it's also what what what what what you're
dealing with now absolutely
absolutely this is a topic that we've been
dealing with for a long time because many of
our partners who are based in the USA or
also in China clearly
showed us off, we were new  how do
you do that and of course we have a
huge advantage we have 30
years of data if you now combine data with technology
at the speed
you have a completely different output and that's what's
happening to us right now we did
n't think it would happen so quickly
but  We just have a treasure trove of gold
and we are now enriching this treasure trove of gold
with people with AI and this
creates things that don't
exist yet. Let's look at this data because I
always hear that so often when I say
okay, but what exactly do you have of
course  now names of customer specific
not so then I would be in
prison then I wouldn't be
sitting here so relaxed but we have
results we just have we have
results from campaigns that we
have evaluated in a way that hardly anyone
can evaluate because we have been doing it for 30
years  We have our own system in the evaluation
and we simply have learnings,
it's not as data at all, it's as
learnings that we know exactly, okay, you
come to us now and have a
beautiful mattress like Emma,
we can take a look and say the
probability that we will now
have more success  in your euro investment it
is much, much larger for us than it is for
others because of all the learnings
we have. I'm moving away from data, says
learnings and if you have
the learnings from over 1000 campaigns over the last 30 years,
you have millions of them
Learnings that are like a big bible
and we work with them,
we are now using AI, data from
30 years ago is still relevant today Jain,
so I believe everything we learn, we
come into the world naked and stupid,
everything we have learned  is relevant
and that's why we're still looking closely
at some behaviors are still
relevant but of course we're
already looking at the last three to five years and
modeling that but forward we're
only looking forward mediaaplan is
always looking forward that's why I'm
only allowed to use it  We'll have to
look forward, I'm probably too old and they
think what does he want in the
past? Let him run, but that's
exactly what makes us special. We have a
team that can only run forward
and of course they're currently running with
AI connected to our treasure of gold  at
nohau and that's just
not a lot of fun and that's also very important to Genen
Dubai and Genen internationalization
right now and also important for partners,
so we're currently building a
real marketplay of partners
where you get exactly the right tools so you can
be on your own  in
this world and to have your own cosm
but others can have it
aha tell me what
you do is in the end to
encourage consumption you want to, so
to speak, deliberately
tempt people in a negative way to buy,
so capitalism in its purest form
can also be thrown at us  but
now I experience you as someone who
loves the world, who also has a demeanor like that,
who
goes through the world a bit artistically and and then there is Sri
Lanka Ayurveda, someone like you
still privately believes in
Catalism, totally totally, totally, I think  It's also
good, it's also a part of us, so I
believe in it and that will also be our
life somewhere. Voices on the other
side, myself. That sounds
strange now because I have a great life. I
'm also incredibly grateful, but I
could also do without it  I experience both
and I fully believe in it, although
if you travel around the world you
can probably see the occasional negative aspects of capitalism. I
mean we all know that the best
system has many bad ones
I see a lot of the negative side
that you'll probably
see even more when you're in
all these places now, absolutely that's why
I also have so much that keeps my
mind right there and I also know where I
come from and that's why we were
there last week  India and then you just notice that
I'm fascinated by that, that's what attracts me
and that's me too, that's
probably my soul and that's what I bring
with me again and again. I tell
our young people agency I
try to let them grow with it. I
also tell ours  Customers on the
other hand, we learn a lot and I
think we are all in the world for
a sense and the mix of capitalism
plus this learning that you have from
other countries that are doing well differently
and then things aren't going bad  I would have bet
someone like you who says okay, I've been doing it for
20 or 30 years now,
that was good and right in the same phase,
but now I want to
do something different, now I want to concentrate on
other types of projects
and then one  Give it
away every day but you don't think like that
so you no because I'm still being used in a different way
so I question it every year
I go to my people every year and
say do you still need me I'm
still the one who can lead you do
you still listen to me  and as
long as I see the fire in my eyes
and and see that I really see that
my ideas are still very valuable for
our partners for our customers for
our team and I just see I see
the huge potential I still have so
much vision for life  gave me so much
fire and we still have so
much music in there a lot is still happening,
not even a small thing in
my opinion, but I mean every now and then
people contact me and say, man, I have to
talk to investors here somehow, I ask that  really out of serious
curiosity that means you own it 100%
you could say man now
I'm selling myself 20 30 so I'm
already interested in it but a lot more to
maybe multiply it into
other areas to say hey
there's a great partner in there  India in
China I can't afford it on my own,
how do we get things
put together in an entrepreneurial way in order
to design this crazy journey that we are currently on there differently and there are
already ideas there,
we are also working on it to simply but not
for capital reasons or  Something I'm
doing super super well living is good to
me and that's not measured by the euro
but by other things
but since this trip from the Mediaplan has
to be reinforced absolutely that will
definitely be an issue because you see
this whole agency world too  I'm
critical myself, so I mean, every now and then when
I talk to people about media agencies,
I hear a
lot of criticism about the procedures, about the
lack of transparency, a little bit about enrichment,
so some say but also human, totally
great service, so it's very
difficult to understand  In the world,
they take a lot of money from the
agency in total and then
something comes back to you. You don't know what
was paid, how was the
action taken with the
publishers, there are a lot of, let's say,
bad stories, we are too  I've
already gone to prison, how do
you look at this
entire world? Well, I've heard that too,
yes, I
suspect I can only say we act
differently, everyone says no, but we just
try to do long-term business
and
transparency and partnership are for us
Important, of course, we also have to
earn money but I mean the numbers
are officially there today and we do
n't have two numbers, there
is a Bible and we just try to
follow it, so we try
our way, that's why we have 30
years and trust  Transparency for us is
important, basically the industry
is so educated whether it will continue to exist like this for a long time
you will see in
other countries things have already
changed but of course you learn again
from other markets where returns
of 50% are normal and in
our industry  Industry yes where where is it like that in
Dubai
for exampleow yes but it will
probably never happen at mirap because
we think differently because we work differently what kind of
return is
normal in Germany let's say for the
industry I would now like to see my
colleagues  ask, I can only speak for myself
and but so normal, I'll say something like
15%, I think even more, even
more, okay, so I think if you
talk to great colleagues of mine with
whom I have a lot of respect, if they
bring home 15%  They would
n't have a job anymore, okay, big problem, okay,
on the other hand, that's for you, but
if you were now at 140
million, let's say it was
somehow 20% for you, then that would be
30 million a year
you could do that
with you, you could do that, yes
you could do that,
our lives won't change either, so that's
Mediaplan, but we also invest
a lot in customers, in projects, in
employees, in training and so on, that's
why  what you earn and
what's left, you can't even
say what it is ktik z that you
hear about medagent W saying that's
true, yes, I think that means
there are, from time to time, there are agreements in the
background that the customer doesn't know
and  Something like that has already
happened, I do
n't think so, but I can only say how we
are, we are really transparent
and I think it's give and
take if the customer is fair and lets
you live then it's all good, but
some  Nowadays you almost have to
be transparent and that's why
a lot of things have been uncovered in
Germany, a lot of things are going well
and there were certainly cases up
until a few years ago where
someone was already caught because money was, so to speak,
contaminated  Giving the customer out to him for
marketing then
somehow went
back to him through opaque channels, so Philip, you're absolutely right,
but I think that the agencies are
already paying attention to the fact that we
already have a need for transparency and
that everyone plays a healthy game on
everyone's behalf  different way
but I can only speak for ourselves, we are
different there and we just try to
go our way without
looking left and right and with us everyone can
look at the books we say R is what's
important for us, let's take the
long term  what to build but of course the
industry we have to live and we live
well, I think we're all doing
well, no one can complain about it, but
of course there are also many international
networks of listed companies,
different things are expected from us, 100%
with me. Mar is your icon
Industry no or clearly clearly wow it's great that
you give people respect but also the
same I also has a certain s
not a trail of blood but also
a trace behind him of course
of course but that's probably why the industry
is where it is and
me  I told you, I do
n't know much about it either because we're no longer a
media agency, we're
big
partners, okay, we're going out of there, okay,
okay, um, in the future, somehow,
you'll carry on like this for the next few
years Dubai  Is there still something promised, something else
planned, so there's something
bigger that's just around the corner
for you, absolutely Dubai is
just the gate in the middle and we'll
see how the journey continues,
but medplan is becoming more and more of a cosmos
But that doesn't mean that now it means how
others do it, now we'll open
an office there, an office there. On
the one hand, we go to other countries with our partners,
we internationalize
with a project with a partner, but we
still have such a dream and  That's like
I've already said,
duck into his money storage, I'll be
happy to jump into the song storage, I
'll be happy to set up topics depending on the customer,
just to say, dear
Philip, how many addresses do you need
this year? We generate them
globally using various mechanisms
international so address generation what
does address generation also do
particularly well in it yes also
song generation maybe also completely
new topics we want we want to
be pioneers we are pioneers and we
have special teams with us that
only develop new things in the way you have
made it fascinating  So
doing that doesn't just mean
campaigning and saying how much B do
you have now, but how can we
promote issues that the world needs right now?
Germany is too small for me,
but my world
is so beautiful and it can
be anywhere and there  There's a lot right now, I
mean someone who how many days in a
normal month are you in Baden Baden
in the office probably a couple of days, oh yeah,
they don't carry me anymore but
hey the rest of the days you're really traveling around
the world in a suitcase
on the way I'll just see what's best for us what's best
for it teams so
today in Hamburg if you so to speak
we're kind of at the end of November now what kind of
trip do you still have ahead of you
so next week we're going to Brazil we're going to
look at markets there
Very interesting options from Brazil
then we go again to Dubai
then we have two more three real topics to
rock then Christmas is
in the way with two but then you do that
at Christmas no then we are in de
in Thailand Christmas
yes that
's okay  But can you
run a 100-person company like this
from a distance, so to speak, then
you can if you have a great team around,
if there is trust, if there
is transparency, if you say
look at Brazil, then
that's real  So you fly to Rio
and then you look at it somehow or is
your wife allowed to fly with you
on the way then the two of you fly to
Rio and talk to other
agency operators, there talks to big
customers and look then something like that goes on and
then you fly on  Yes, exactly, we
just look at how we can do
things that are now successful over there,
how can we transport them
to which markets, how can we
copy or redevelop systems? Above all,
you don't have to reinvent everything,
but sometimes this
cooperation is also our network  is
huge and it will surprise a lot
in the future because it means we can
simply create new things and I
just want to create new things and that's
why we never look at what
others are doing and what is the
status quo that bores me, we
always look forward  I'm just imagining all the energy I've got in front of
me,
like Brazilian agency operators sitting there
and then Crazy
German Frank comes along and then you tell me a
little bit about what you could do.
They're really excited about Germany
because they say hey Germany is us
I think of it in a completely different way, and that it
works relatively well, yes, and that
's why we also believe that markets
will connect, that topics
will connect more, that the world
will become more global and that we
have the technical requirements. You have
addressed genres for many media  and that's how it will be for
many markets South America will become a very
important market for us that wants to go
to Europe in the future.
We are also a gateway, meaning you
want to go to Brazil and
then bring companies from there to Germany,
yes, but we also connect
content topics  Let's take a close look
at what they do, what they do great
and learn something new every day and also have
this openness, give people the
freedom with us and say that here they take
what is developed with them, the way you did it
cool here, um, that's
how it is  that, um, if you are now
traveling in Thailand, in Dubai, in Brazil,
that all these people there are
interested in Germany, I mean,
in the world geography is so
to speak, the German market has
become a little, um, less relevant,
perhaps in the last few years  New
markets
want to be created that all want to go to Germany, that
all of Germany is so strongly on the
list. Germany is still
such a target region in the
future for the people there. So
of course we sense a change,
but I think we're not allowed to Germany
either  Talking too badly, talking too small,
we are over 80 million
people,
we have many, many advantages that are
underestimated. Of course, it becomes interesting
if you put Germany Austria Switzerland
together, for example in South America, then
it becomes more interesting, but we
see Europe itself and we see the
whole world  Germany stands alone,
you have to work a little harder
now, tell more success stories
like you used to have to tell,
but that's easy for me because I think
Germany is still great, we
can't and shouldn't badmouth everything
that's here and you can feel that
outside too  Even if you are a positive
woman going outside with showcases then
you already have Germany absolutely on your
radar, what kind of products are there now
in Brazil or from me in
Dubai that you could bring here so
what do they want to sell us?
Travel to Brazil, I understand that  What do
we want? Brazil, for example, has developed very
special retail marketing measures
that don't exist here yet.
I think it's really exciting, completely different
ways and we want to see if they
can also be used here in Germany. This isn't
about Brazilian companies  the what the
digital company gives an incredible amount of
digital Brazil has an incredible
energy and an insane so banks
digital banks or e.g. B onl shops yes
also food delivery companies in a completely
different way sustainable companies that
develop sustainable energies
over there in Europe want and and
so  You haven't done much
in China yet, but what does that
mean? The way to
grow is through internationalization.
Growing in Germany is more
difficult because the market is spread out.
There's a lot of competition. No, no, in
Germany, oh God, the market is  no matter
how big it is, it's so wonderful because we
have so many young, fresh companies,
we have fascinating new companies
that have now joined Mediaplan this year  ca
n't move yet look not very many unicorns
and let's say very very dynamic
companies npal Emma so all of them with you
are absolutely absolute and where we all
started small and that's exactly
mediapan that's why these companies are exactly the right fit for us and they
say hey we
we're really up for it, we're standing there now,
waterdop and so on, we're standing there, we've got plans for
the next few years
and we're exactly the right person. You're
a
bit like a venture
capitalist, so he's also thinking about where
Do I put my chips on what do
I believe, who am I developing with absolutely that's
why a lot of investors come to
us and say hey Frank, pay attention, we
would like to buy number 2 in Germany,
what do we need to become number 1,
that means that then you'll see  We
're not just an agency, we're
really a match for smart people
for investors for business pictures and that's
why our journey is just
at the beginning and they write
as they say the cover letters say
man Frank here I've just
invested in endp red  with those and
something like that, exactly the same, I mean if you
look at your business performance now, you built a company with 140 sales,
I don't know if it's true or not, but something like that,
you can make a result of 15 20 million € with it or can
you do that in good years
you've been doing it for I don't know somehow 20 or 30
years P thumb your fingers then you've
already received a lot of millions
plus you've created a company
that would probably be worth
100 million plus if you sold it,
so there you are
really a very successful
entrepreneur in Germany who is often
not even on your list, no,
I think that's also the nice thing, it's
a bit of my culture and you
experience me now, I'm allowed to
be different and I don't attach any
importance to it  I'm not on the list, it's
the people who know me
who appreciate me and I'm very
grateful to them for their care, but I'm
not the loudest and we're not the
acquirers. Mediaplan doesn't run around
begging for money, Mediaplan
is recommended to others  and I think that's
something important and we impress with
our energy in terms of performance and
strategies, innovation and speed and that's
why there are a lot of great people
who surround us like Rüdiger Hartung and
Nicole Weber who are just keen on us and
say hey, I can do that
I've experienced a lot myself.
Andreas Seifer, they all
accompany us on the paths that simply
say wow, there's such a small cosm
that you may not even know about, but
you are an important growing partner and
driving force for the entire industry and I'm here
I'm proud of it so many of the
dietes Rüdiger Andreas
Nicole we also say what I know
better
so yes great respect for the
performance you wouldn't have guessed when we
first got to know each other or
somehow I got the intro to you
I was surprised, what is
that
but yes W look at the number we did
a bit of research
big respect thank
you I don't think I
managed to reveal your data secrets exactly in the end
so what special things you can do with the data now
others can't
do so we can  Yes,
try it, but have you explained what
you can give or say a little bit,
what has to remain our secret? So it's
very clear that we don't have that
much of a secret
combined with technology and if
people feel like it and can also
read data, you can do completely different things, so
today it is much easier for us
to write our own systems, but we
can say invest in Mediaplan in
the industry that and that will roughly
come out and for that  Let's use the
learnings that we simply have,
i.e. human technology, our own technology
but also really self-
written software, so
we have if you asked me 5
years ago technology, I
always ran away and Rüdiger
always encouraged me to do it, Frank said that
These are the people you do
n't have to be interested in, but they are so
important to you and they've
just made it. Now we have a
really great unit. People who only
deal with the learnings with our tressor of experiences.
I mean, I can't do it  I mean, there
are other
media agencies as well, I used them
because due to the large total volume that
you then spend on many customers,
you then get discounts from the respective media-
owning television stations and so on,
sometimes at Google and so on,
but there are no discounts elsewhere  partly
yes and but that's not crucial for you now
because there are
others who have a lot more purchasing power, but
for us the crucial thing is
how much is old money what is fresh
money how much do you produce how many
companies do you help  grow because
for media companies, of course, they live
from pitches from et shifts
for us, the mile houses how much
we will produce next year in
fresh money how much we can
develop companies to
give companies strength to grow that is exactly
our topic and to take this power
and  with companies that maybe
start with €100,000 to suddenly give them the
strength and success
to spend 5 million or 10
million that's Mediaplan and that's why
we are a completely different partner for
media houses and lives completely different dr
a few more customers  They are
now more in the 100,000 range where you
believe in it right now, you say man, they
could be big in the future, do
you have any currently where say man, they
just joined us
and we're making more of it now,
we have a lot of them, so I have to say  We
have connected over 20 new projects this year alone
mediaaplan I do
n't want to single out any of them now
otherwise I'll get a beating
from the team next week but also a person
I'm in front of like hell Mirco Kasper with
Dr Spex knows where they started, I
think with 50,000  € started with us and
this partnership is now a
partnership and friendship, the ex has been around
for almost 10 years now and we've
known K, he's actually the one who
looks at the topics with mckinse glasses, he's now no one who's
actually there for any
crazy people  Visions are given but good,
so a bit of a secret has to remain.
I'll finish the story. Thank you
very much for coming around and making a quick stop in Hamburg on your world travels,
so to
speak